Alors pour mieux comprendre
la situation critique là-bas,
j'en parle avec vous,
Dre Nathalie Boulanger,
parce que vous pratiquez depss
30 dans le Nord-du-Québec.
Alors pouvez-vous nous expliquer
quelles sont les conséquences
de cette crise-là en ce moment?
Dre NAALALIE BOULANGER, médecin
dir. méd. régionale du Nunavik
- Bien, les conséquences,
c'est qu'on ne peut s'occuper
que des urgences présentement.
Donc toute la vaccination,
le suivi des enfants, les suivis
des maladies chroniques comme
le diabète, les patients
qui reviennent de Montréal
avec des problèmes de santé
qui doivent... qui nécessitent
un suivi plus ou moins serré,
c'est mis de cô c complètement.
C'est sûr que ça va avoir
des conséquences sur la santé
de la population, qui est déjà
précaire, parce qu'on a des gens
qui... une population qui a beau
être jeune, pardon, qui a
quand même un état de santé
beaucoup moins solide que dans
les populations qu'on retrouve
autour de Montréal.
Ça fait que là, nous, le groupe
de médecins, on est inquiets de
ça parce quon se dit : Qu'est-ce
nous attend à l'automne?
Est-ce qu'on va trouve
des choses épouvantables
dans les patients qu'on n'a pas
réussi à voir jusqu'à maintenant
parce que c'était pas des
urgences de vie ou de mort, là?
- Des choses que vous aurez
pas pu diaosostiquer à temps.
Qu'est-ce qui peut expliquer
en fait tout ça? Pourquoi
il manque autant de médecins
et d'infirmières?stst-ce que
c'est les conditions difficiles,
les salaires? C'est quoi?
- Un peu de tout. Moi, ça fait
31 ans que je travaille au Nord.
On ne vit que dans ça,
la pénurie, puis gérer
les difficultés de recrutement,
puis de rétention de personnel.
nnnnêtement, j'ai jamais vu ça
aussi pire que ça cette année.
Je pense que ça s'explique
de plusieurs façons.
Oui, c'est pas facile de vivre
au Nunavik, on n'a pas de réseau
Internet... Bien, le réseau
Internet, il y en a un,
mais c'est vraiment...
- C'est déficient.
- C'est décicient, il n'y a pas
de cellulaire, c'est difficile
de se rendre; dans les villages
de l'Hudson particulièrement,
y y a des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en eau
et de... de...
- C'est pas encourageant
finalement pour
les professionnels.
- Non, c'est difficile,
c'est ça.
- Mais là, Christian Dubé
va se rendre sur place,
on l'a entendu. Est-ce que
vous pensez que ça va faire
une différen q que le ministre
de la Santé prenne la peine
de se déplacer?
- Moi, je pense que c'est
toujours une bonne idée
qu'un ministre de la Santé
vienne visiter le Nunavik
parce que ça ouvre les yeux.
C'est une... Même si on lui
en parle, même s'il fait
des lectures, même s'il voit
des photos, c'est rien comparé
à quand on met les pieds dans
l'hôpital, puis on constate
la vétusté des lieux, le manque
de personnel, les gens qui ont
l'air fatigués parce que ça fait
plusieurs nuits qu'ils n'ont pas
dormi. Ça fait que je pense
que ça va être très positif
de ce côté-là.
Là, reste à savoir
si miraculeusement, il va
être capable de sortir
six infirmières de sa poche
en trois jours. Je sais pas.
- rcrce que vous, comme médecin,
vous avez besoin des infirmières
parce que sinon, vous vous
retrouvez à avoir beaucoup plus
de tâches à accomplir
et ça devient exténuant
pour les médecins.
- Bien, le système de santé
au Nunavik repose sur
les infirmières cliniciennes et
les infirmières qu'on appelle
à rôle élargi. Les infirmières
à rôle élargi, c'est des
infirmières cliniciennes qui ont
à leur disposition un recueil
d'actes délégués qui leur permet
de diagnostiquer, traiter
des conditions assez courantes
comme les otites, une infection
urinaire, des choses comme ça.
Quand il n'y a pas d'infirmière
pour faire ce travail-là,
bien évidemment, les médecins
doivent aller porter aide
aux infirmières, mais alors,
le travail qu'ils doivent faire
normalement n'est pas fait.
- Christian Dubé parlait
d'un plan de contingence qui est
en train de se mettre en place.
Il y a la Croix-Rouge qui va
y participer. Il disait ee
des médecins des autres
provinces pourraient être
envoyés en renfort,
des ambulanciers, ncnc des
paramédics sont même en route.
Est-ce que vous croyez que
ça va fonctionner, le plan de
continncnce, ou il faudra plus
que ça?
- Le problème avec ça, c'est que
ce n'est pas des... T'sais, on a
bebesoin de monde pour vendredi;
on est mercredi. La Croix-Rouge,
ça prend du temps, ils n'ont pas
des infirmières qui sont
chez elles à rien faire.
Donc ils nous disent : dans
le mieux des cas, ça va être
en septembre. Les médecins qui
viennent d'autres provinces,
bien, il y a toute la
complication avec : as-tu
un permis de pratique au Québec?
Est-ce que tu parles français?
As-tu des assurances?
- Beaucoup de choses à penser.
- Beaucoup de choses à penser,
ça fait que c'est sûr que c'est
possible que ça va se faire,
mais à court terme, à très court
terme, quand on fait face à
la possibilité d'être obligé
de fermer un dispensaire, puis
de dire à la population : "Bien,
c'est de valeur! Si vous avez
un problème de santé, il y aura
personne pour vous traiter."
C'est sûr qu'à court terme,
c'est des bonnes solutions..
C'est des bonnes solutions à
moyen terme, mais à court terme,
ça nous donne peu de choses.
- C'est quoi les solioions
à long terme justement?
- Bien, moi, je pense que
ça passe par une réorganisation
du travailT'T'sais, la pénurie
de personnel est vécue
à la grandeur du Québec.
Puis là, on parlait tantôt, moi,
laénénurie, on vit ça depuis
30 ans, mais ce qui nous sauvait
avant, c'est qu'il y avait quand
même un bassin d'infirmières
au Sud puis de médecins au Sud
qu'on était capable de recruter
temporairement. Mais là,
c'est comme si ça n'existe plus,
il n'y en a plus. Les agences
sont vides, les médecins
sont tous occupés à travailler
ailleurs. Donc...
- Est-ce qu'il faudrait l'armée
justement? L'armée, est-ce que
c'est...
- Bien, on n'a pas besoin
d'un régiment de l'armée. On a
besoin d'infirmière surtout puis
de médecin, puis le nombre dont
on a besoin, c'est pas 30-40,
là! C'est d'une poignée de monde
qu'on a besoin pour être en
mesure de donner les services.
Même dans les plus gros
dispensaires ou les plus gros
CLSC, les infirmières qui font
la première ligne sont peu
nombreuses. T'sais, des fois,
elles sont six, mais souvent
elles sont quatre.
Ça fait qu'on comprend que
s'il t'en manque 2 sur, , bien,
t'as 50 % de ta force de travail
qui vient de partir, puis c'est
pour ça qu'on tombe en rupture
de services si facilement.
Les médecins, c'est la même
chose. T'sais, moi, j'ai deux
médecins qui travaillent...
J'ai deux postes de médecins qui
travaillent à Salluit. Si jamais
ils étaient trois, ils seraient
trop; mais quand ils sont un,
c'est pas assez. Ça fait que
t'sais, c'est difficile aussi
de pvovoir ou dire : on va en
engager plus au cas où on aurait
pas de place. Pas pas de
place... On aurait besoin.
- Donc c'est beaucoup
de travail quand même qui attend
le ministre Dubé pour corriger
cette situation-là. Et vous,
vous allez quand même continuer
de travailler sur place?
Vous êtes quand même motivée
- Bien, oui. Moi, mon coeur
est au Nunavik. Ça fait...
T'sais, je serais partie depuis
longtemps. Moi, je trouve que
c'est la plus belle pratique
au monde, de travailler avec
les populationauautochtones
dans les petits villages aussi
où tu finis par connaître tout
le monde. Moi, dans le village
où j'ai pratiqué le plus
longtemps, il y a personne que
je ne connais pas. Quand je vois
un patient, bien, je connais
sa mère, sa grand-mère. Ça fait
des liens que tu ne retrouves
pas ailleurs.
- Mais c'est admirable,
en tout cas. Merci beaucoup,
puis je vous souhaite bon retour
au Nunavik en espérant justement
que ça fasse une différenc q que
le ministre se rende sur place.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Bonne soirée.
- Bonne soirée